well i might need a hat if there's going
to be rain out there my people is a
fashion platform that promotes latinx
talent in the us and they are hosting a
special pop-up this week right here in
las vegas and here to tell us more about
their brand and their mission we have
co-founders linda wisebow and katherine
bachelier yes yes we were practicing
this i love that you guys thank you for
being here i want to talk all about this
because you guys are doing some really
incredible things but tell me a little
bit about my people and what it's all
about okay so my thank you first of all
of course my people is a pop and shop
it's a we're um
a broker for mexican brands coming into
the united states we're so excited to be
able to do two things that we love
fashion and promoting mexico and mexican
fashion because there's so many amazing
amazing designers in mexico there is so
much talent there is high quality we
want to show the world really the world
that you can find some really amazing
things
but we can help you find those
yeah we're kind of like cool hunters in
a way we look for all the cool stuff and
then we bring it to you i love the name
that is the most amazing title and at
the beginning of the show we were
talking about seeing all this stuff kind
of set up off to the side i love the
colors and the vibrancy let's talk about
some of the pieces we have on the table
here okay let's start with uno mas
right over here yep we have her at
nordstrom whatever you guys are wearing
yes we're always wearing these actually
we have to say every time we pop up i
think this is going to be our fifth or
our sixth pop-up they ask us to
be back with bringing it keep bringing
it to us because i love it it's just
cool and funky we also have right here
as you see santo pecado
we love the artistry because it's simple
it's easy you can wear it in the ocean
you can wear in this handle in the beach
everywhere and this is all handmade in
tokyo
wow these are all handmade by artisans
in leon guanajuato so every single piece
here comes from a different region in
mexico and it's all supporting local
artisans exactly i love shopping kind of
four cods but spreading a mission and
you get to feel good while you're doing
it i love that it looks fantastic yes i
said i loved your hat when you walked in
tell me about these hats okay these hats
we found in san miguel de allende
they're called palomina
and looking so cute on you the the
designer her name is suki okay suki and
she combines classic style with very
funky
cool colors they're very lightweight
they're perfect for the summer and it's
a perfect example of what we see in
mexico obviously we have artisan type
very mexican themed but we also have
very modern and what mexico is doing so
well right now is it's mixing its old
heritage tradition with new modern funky
amazing things which brings us to
alicia von konstan elisheven constanza
and so what this stunning yeah what this
designer does is
it's everything is 24 carat dip so
you'll see that very very bright yellow
yes bright gold but it has a lot of
modern something texture
yeah well i have my eye on that you guys
i have my eye on everything and really
quickly the pop-up is happening this
week at fashion show where can people
come see you guys you can come visit us
at nordstrom fashion show thursday
friday saturday please come shop come
visit come take pictures come help
promote all of these beautiful amazing
designers melinda catherine thank you so
much all your information on your screen
and i'm loving this hat mercedes i'll
send it over to you